[Music]
[Applause]
rick stroud covers the tampa bay
buccaneers for the tampa bay times he
also hosts sports day tampa bay his
podcast and joins us on the program i
know you were at practice yesterday but
what did you hear when ryan jensen went
down with that injury at practice
a horrible scream dan that i've only
heard once before and that's when a guy
on a basketball court tore his acl and
it's unmistakable
i think everybody knew that it was a
serious injury we're waiting for
the proverbial news but
you know when you see a bunch of guys
gather around
a cart like that and and you know
wish him well you know that he's not
coming back to play anytime soon give
this audience an idea of how important
ryan jensen is to this team's success
well i mean i think on the offensive
line uh arguably he's the most important
guy right i mean when tom brady decided
to unretire within hours the first
player they signed or re-signed was ryan
jensen who had an offer from the
cincinnati bengals and it was that
important to tom brady um you know when
you're talking about
that relationship
you know
calling out the signals the line of
scrimmage but more than that he's a tone
center for that entire offensive line
and you know brady is very particular uh
right down to whether a guy wears a
glove or how much baby powder he puts in
his rear end i mean he's he's on it
right and and i think it's a it's a huge
loss
because of all that ryan jensen
represents and if you go back all you
got to do is watch the washington game
last year
and and tom brady gets hit within the
first two plays
uh hard inside and he's not the same
player the rest of the game and i i
think that interior offensive line where
they've got two new guards now already
with shaq mason and and probably aaron
stinney um
now you've got to replace the center
it's not going to be easy
bigger deal losing gronk adding kyle
rudolph for adding julio jones
wow
um
probably losing gronk
probably that's a bigger deal simply
because when he when he could play when
he was healthy
he's the greatest tight end of all time
and the synergy that he had
with tom brady is second to almost none
in nfl history so you know gronk did so
many things and he also brought an
attitude to the building you can't
replace he never had a bad day dan he's
exactly as you see him on tv man uh and
i i think they're gonna miss that and
and that's why i think julio is here in
part to try to make up for those 55
catches 800 yards and five touchdowns i
mean you've got to get that somewhere
you're not going to get it from kyle
rudolph necessarily so that's a really
big loss it's kind of incalculable
really
julio jones what's he have left at what
age 33
yeah well for one day man he was he put
on a highlight
it was impressive you could have just
bottled up the first day out there he
was they were throwing fades to him and
he was jumping over guys and mossing
people it was impressive
so that shows you what the upside is you
know the thing is can he stay healthy
and that's that's been his deal the last
two years he's missed 14 games um and i
think that the bucks will be smart and
try to keep him on some kind of a pitch
count if nothing else you consider what
he can do in the red zone with guys like
mike evans and godwin when he gets back
and uh you know russell gage and cam
brait i mean they've they've got some
some problems for defenses and so um but
just you know just his pedigree i mean
they said the other day tristan worth
said it's like it's like a fantasy team
he goes you know it's like a video game
you you know if you're in the transfer
portal in the nfl you're coming to tampa
i mean it doesn't matter you know
they're the all-name team but that's
that's what this year is about and it's
what it's always about with tom brady is
brady done talking about retirement
well we haven't talked to him yet so
we're going to ask him about it let me
talk to him one time in the off season
yeah to answer your question i i think
he is um you know he's decided to play
this year
my my guess is he's done playing in
tampa but unlike last last year you know
at the end of the season when he decided
to retire he really didn't know what he
was going to do we know now that he has
a deal at fox uh you know to to call
games for 37 and a half million not a
bad not a bad secondary job so um at
least he's got that in his pocket and i
think he'll you know when it's over
he'll reassess like he every day always
does but it depends does the does the
season end in confetti or condolence dan
i mean i you know the greatest players
in any sport have trouble walking away
and and he can absolutely still play
don't get me wrong his arm looks live
and it's amazing what he's been able to
do he could probably do it till he's 50
years old um but i think that uh at
least as far as the bucks are concerned
they're looking at this as as the last
dance so to speak have you used that in
the column have you used confetti in
condolence and already
i'm not sure if i have i'm a very
alliterative guy dan it's very good it's
very nice but also you look at this deal
with fox if tom had gone to miami which
is what he wanted to do
and then he would played for sean payton
and then he would slipped into ownership
there
jimmy garoppolo could be with the
buccaneers right now
no he couldn't no
no no way
if tom wasn't there would they wouldn't
they would have made a run
he was on a list but he wasn't high on
the list i mean the thing the thing i
was told about jimmy is like if you're
gonna run it 40 times a game that's
great but if he could throw the deep
ball down he'd have two more super bowl
rings right now and the one he has tom
brady won so i i don't think jimmy was
was was high on their list there were
other guys um you know and they weren't
going to kick the tires on the sean
watson the ownerships told him no baker
mayfield was probably on that list but
it would not have been uh quite the same
vibe uh with any of those guys to say
the least are the buccaneers a
threatening team
yes to win at all to win it all yes okay
you know who their quarterback is right
yeah well i i know but it's still
like no they're listen they they have
done some things in the off season um
and and this injury you can't quantify
how how big it is because it really is
big um but i think you know defensively
dan they had to get more athletic they
let in domicon sue jason pierre paul go
they drafted um logan hall they brought
in akeem hicks um you know they're gonna
let joe try on shawinka come off the
edge as the first round pick they had a
year ago they're more athletic they got
better in the secondary with depth with
keanu neal uh and uh you know uh
well where would you put them in the
hierarchy maybe the question should have
been phrased better listen i i don't
think they're any worse than third best
team in the nfc uh totally i mean look
the rams you give it to them they're
defending super bowl champions you you
would figure that green bay is in that
mix um but they're no worse than third
and probably second i think
we'll be in touch i'm sure there'll be
reason to give you a call rick as always
great stuff thanks for joining us
next crisis i'm here for you buddy
that's rick stroud covers the buccaneers
tampa bay times i thought it was
interesting that he talked about now
certainly the severity and the value of
ryan jensen but also if tom brady had
gone to the dolphins which that was his
game plan he wanted to go there be the
quarterback and then
he was going to eventually move up and
be part owner of the the miami dolphins
and then i thought well would tampa have
reached out to jimmy garoppolo
and then rick's saying no
not at all
and then you start to go okay desean
watson no ownership wasn't interested
baker mayfield i mean maybe baker
mayfield
and uh and i wondered if baker was going
to end up in tampa
you know this past summer i thought
maybe you bring him in let him learn
from tom
and that he would be the eventual
successor there
uh i don't know what their plans are
going to be as they move forward with
brady it feels like this is his last
year and i wonder if gronk doesn't come
back if and he he brought up is it going
to be confetti or condolences
which it feels that's what it is for tom
brady it's either you win it or
nothing else comes close
like he doesn't he doesn't deal in
participation trophies second place this
is about winning another super bowl here